all right so you saw that last night on
the channel that's joe biden essentially
taking credit for the ceasefire between
israel and hamas it was actually
brokered by egypt
not by the united states let's bring in
fox and friends weekend co-hosts pete
hegseth and will kane
hey pete you know for him to be taking
credit
that's like him saying that he was
taking credit for killing bin laden
when we know that in fact he said you
know what i don't think this is a good
idea
let's not do it boss that's true and
ultimately we know
the outcome of that was a positive one
in killing midland what remains to be
seen is
whether that not this ceasefire is
ultimately positive for the state of
israel whether they had
sufficient time to exact the type of
price that hamas needs to pay
for firing indiscriminate rockets deeper
than ever
into the state of israel so there's
there is always a peace to be found on
the other side of war and in this
particular case
israel did what it needed to do for a
very short period of time
to attempt to decimate a terrorist
network the question is is it enough
and what role did joe biden truly play
he started out at the beginning saying
israel has a right to defend itself then
the hamas caucus
the far left wing of his party pressured
and pressured and pressured him
there was a lot of moral equivalency
from this administration between the two
which is
absolutely false and now we still see
them dabbling with an iran deal
which would enrich the iranian regime
and and
allow them to get closer to the nuclear
weapon when that's the regime
supplying hamas in the first place so it
remains to be seen whether this is a
good thing
all i care is whether or not bibi
netanyahu and israel feel like
they got the price paid from hamas that
they needed at this moment for
deterrence
well we want you to weigh in on this
topic border patrol they
they uh get 32 mexican nationals
they were crossing they came over from
mexico they were the arizona new mexico
border
they're dressed in camouflage what was
your reaction to that
well that it was an arrest that
reflected exactly what i saw a few weeks
ago when i went to the arizona border
for fox and friends ainsley
i saw firsthand the camouflage discarded
on the loadout zones there where the
the migrants take off the the cartel
issued camouflage
the carpet shoes they use to move
quietly through the desert backpacks
full of whatever it is they bring
into the united states it just backs up
everything the sheriff
mark lamb and others showed me there in
arizona and by the way we got to
participate in a border patrol arrest
and guess what
those migrants were also mexican
nationals wearing that exact
outfit right there that is a great
illustration of what is happening at the
southern border in arizona
you know what will i think the people of
arizona it goes beyond
politics because you have both
democratic senators
in arizona coming out saying something
has to be done at the border because
they know they have no political future
because the people of arizona don't care
about republicans democrats their life
skills could be coming chaos
because of that uh that porous border
hey brian two things two quick points on
what i heard
it's about the rule of law do you want
to live in a place where it seems like
the rule of law just doesn't apply
nobody obeys the rules and then
secondarily to your point quality of
life
how would you feel somebody's just
always walking through your backyard and
there's nobody you could call to solve
that
it's a quality of life issue sure and
pete what about uh
we had about 20 minutes ago that
congressman from tennessee
uh a couple of weeks ago the federal
government calls the governor of
tennessee and says hey can you take some
of these migrant kids
and he said no we don't have room so
what are they doing
reportedly they are flying them into
airports
in the middle of the night they haven't
told anybody hey yep we've got the kids
coming
because they don't want the folks to
know
why wouldn't they uh they ran scared
from images they didn't want the media
to see
from the beginning at the border because
of a policy they instituted
and rather than address the actual issue
at the border as will's talking about
they tried to make the problem quietly
in the middle of the night go away
i'm surprised they're even asking states
or notifying them and
oftentimes there is no notification
process and people are released and
and mayors are left to deal with it this
is not a border issue
this is coming to a town near you go
ahead uh ainsley
uh wants to know who's going to be on
your show i'd like to be surprised
uh so can you hear me close your eyes
because it's in the challenge
yeah here's the great thing usually pete
and i like to be surprised as well
luckily it's in the prompter maria
salazar the u.n
the israeli ambassador uh to the u.s and
the u.n and there you have it right
there
nancy grace oh she's always a great
guest and will you've been doing a great
job on prime time
i bet you're exhausted you worked all
last year you worked last week when
brian was on shoots and then you worked
all weekend then you worked all week and
then you're working this weekend too
the only thing i have going for is it
killed me is on the same screen as me
right now so
i mean the guy's working 18 hours a day
i don't know i'm exhausted i don't know
how you do it right
well um i would say this the fact that
you're
full screen has you with a beard but yet
we're looking at you live without one it
makes me wonder
who makes that decision do you have a
fashion consultant but
one of them head shots but one of us has
some head shots
one of us has a beard right now because
he has a policy he does not
shave during the week he only shaves on
the weekend when
the paycheck who comes up with that
contract
get a better agent get a better agent
brian
all right guys we're going to be
watching you this weekend and we'll
we'll see you tonight thank you on prime
time thanks guys
right